hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
packe heute eine muttertags torte für
meine mama also für und ich habe mir
gedacht ich mache es wieder eine von
dort hatte ich weiß dass jetzt nichts
sinnvolles dabei auskommen zwar ist im
innern eine erdbeertorte aber nicht eine
normale erdbeertorte sondern die torte
überzeugt mit optik und geschmack dass
eine erdbeer creme drin eine
holunderblüten creme und einem ins creme
also wirklich eine geschmacksexplosion
pur dekoriert habe ich sie dann mit etwa
von dort er schmeckt auch richtig lecker
da sage ich aber später noch was dazu
und hier oben habe ich noch erdbeeren
und blumen modelliert und die torte habe
ich ihnen zwei tagen also an zwei tagen
gebacken
an dem einen tag habe ich die böden
vorgebacken die creme vorbereitet
gefühlt und am zweiten tag dekoriert das
heißt ihr könnt euch das gut einteilen
und ich zeige euch jetzt direkt was wir
dafür benötigen für die torte zuerst um
später mit sie dann dekoriert bei der
torte habe ich mich jetzt für eine
geschmacks kombination entschieden und
zwar eine erdbeertorte mit einer
holunderblüten creme und einer minsk
rehn
ich habe hier bereits wiener böden
vorgebacken mit dem durchmesser 26 cm
habt ihr zwei mal durchgeschnitten also
habe ich drei böden und habe die
retorten also den tortenboden bereits
auf eine tortenplatte gesetz mit etwas
kann es untendrunter da kann nämlich die
platte nicht verschoben werden
die krähen ist eine sahne creme das
heißt ich muss die creme jetzt so in die
torte reihen füllen das später die sahne
creme nicht in kontakt mit dem von dort
kommt weil der sich ansonsten auflöst
weil seine krems einfach viel zu feucht
sind deswegen muss ich jetzt hier
erstmal einen rang spritzen aus ghana
papier bereits eine weiße gallas
vorbereitet und ist es jetzt so eine
möglichkeit um so torte neben sondern
tauglich zu machen
die andere möglichkeit wäre dass man die
torte füllt und später noch mal so ein
bisschen rand außenrum macht die kanal
spricht jetzt nur ganz kurz durch und
führt sie in einer spritzbeutel mit
einer lok thüle
jetzt setzt sich einen tollen rahmen um
die torte
jetzt müsst euch das so vorstellen dass
ich denn hier außen herum einen ring aus
ghana spritze dann bleibt nämlich die
sahne füllung in der torte die
tortenplatte ist übrigens minimal größer
als die torte selbst jetzt spritze ich
das hier direkt außen herum
und dann nochmal eine schicht oben
drüber dann ist der rand etwas höher
und damit die umrandung jetzt etwas
härter wird fahre ich da immer noch mal
mit einer palette entlang
und damit der rahmen jetzt fest wird
stelle ich die torte kurz in den
kühlschrank und kann ihnen der
zwischenzeit schon mal die füllung
vorbereiten für die holunderblüten creme
brauche ich 250 gramm quark 250 gramm ab
ohne 100 milliliter holunderblütensirup
etwas zitronensaft 200 milliliter sahne
seiner fahrt zwei päckchen magazine und
100 milliliter wasser und 300 gramm
erdbeeren erzähle ich die sahne mit zwei
teelöffeln salat steif schlagen
jetzt kann ich die ak tine mit dem
wasser verbrüht
ihr könnt natürlich auch gelatine nehmen
aber ich bevorzuge da immer die
pflanzliche variante
das wasser kommt direkt mit rein das
muss kaltes wasser seien jetzt
berührungs und lass es zwei minuten lang
sprudelt aufgebrochen und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
restlichen zutaten verrühren und zwar
masca promaqua holunderblütensirup und
einem spritzer zitronensaft und das
jetzt noch ganz kurz verrühren bis sich
alles schön verbunden hat
nach zwei minuten kochzeit habe ich
jetzt die akademie vom heruntergezogen
jetzt kann ich direkt ein bisschen von
der quarkmasse einrühren und kann das
dann direkt in die restliche quarkmasse
einfüllen
jetzt habe ich noch schnell die sahne
unter und die masse beginnt auch immer
direkt zu gelieren da müsst ihr euch
deswegen immer ganz gut beeilen
ein ganz kleines bisschen creme verteile
ich jetzt direkt auf dem tortenboden ihr
seht jetzt auch die creme ist schon fest
geworden dass verteidigt ihr könnt jetzt
aber auch zum beispiel etwas marmelade
drauf streichen einfach damit die
erdbeeren so ein bisschen halt haben und
angeben können da kommen jetzt die erste
hälfte drauf die habe ich jetzt bereits
klein geschnitten
darüber verteile ich jetzt einen großen
teil der creme aber lasse etwa vier bis
fünf esslöffel übrig
jetzt muss ich hier gerade ein bisschen
von der überschüssigen ganache weg
nehmen damit ich den mittleren
tortenboden gleich ganz klar aufsetzen
kann
hier spricht sich jetzt noch mal einen
kleinen rand außen rum
denn da kommt jetzt erst noch mal eine
creme drauf und jetzt müsste wirklich
ganz schnell arbeiten da ansonsten die
rest creme die ich mir hier weg gelegt
habe ich mal fest wird die torte stelle
ich kurz kühl und zeigt euch da vorne
die zutaten für die restliche creme
dafür brauche ich zwei esslöffel zucker
eine handvoll minze und ein spritzer
zitronensaft es nämlich direkt zucker
und minze das kann man natürlich auch
vorher vorbereiten bevor man die creme
anrührt und jetzt kommt der zucker auf
die minze darauf dass weg so ein
bisschen unterstützen und ich kann die
minze dann besser fein hacken
die minis durch den zucker jetzt ganz
schön fein und so kommt es jetzt direkt
mit in die restliche creme gemeinsam mit
einem spritzer zitronensaft und einem
gesunden kern den ich wirklich wieder
rausnehmen
dass er jetzt kurz verrührt
damit die krimis ganz glatt wird habe
ich jetzt umgefüllt und setzte einfach
noch durch pürieren
jetzt kann ich die creme auch direkt auf
der torte verteilen
wer möchte und den grüne also diese
grüne farbe noch intensivieren möchte
kann zum beispiel auch ein bisschen
lebensmittelfarbe zufügen
jetzt sehe ich hier nochmal den
überschuss weg und kann dann gleich die
teigplatten draufsetzen den deckel und
dann lasse ich die torte abgedeckt im
kühlschrank rot für mindestens vier bis
fünf stunden bei mir wird es jetzt über
nacht im kühlschrank stehen und ich kann
dann schon mal anfangen etwas dicke
vorzubereiten
bevor ich jetzt die torte mit ghanas 1
streichung mit von dober ziehe stelle
ich erst einmal die deko elemente her
ich brauche dafür etwas weißen und roten
rolle von dollar und etwas grüne modell
ihr schokolade denn es werden die zweite
blumen und rote erdbeer modelliert der
weiße und rote von gollwitz getrennt
voneinander mit etwas cmc pulver also
zellulose pulver verknetet dadurch kann
der von dort nämlich später austrocknen
was brauche ich jetzt für die blumen und
rot für die erdbeeren nicht gibt es
verschiedene möglichkeiten um blumen
herzustellen ich zeige euch jetzt 2
zuerst einmal muss ich jetzt den von
bauer ausrollen
und dann arbeitet jetzt mit einem
ausstecher und einem präge werkzeug und
stich jetzt die blumen aus dass es so
die einfache möglichkeit
und dann wird die blume auf dieses träge
werkzeug draufgelegt leicht angedrückt
und dann drücke ich sie fest und dadurch
erhält dann diese struktur und die blume
muss man dann nur noch zur seite legen
zum beispiel in seinen kleinen teelöffel
rein und dann haben sie auch so ein
bisschen nullrunde und können so
austrocknen
als nächstes habe ich jetzt hier auch
nochmal einen ausstecher und weil es
einen rosen ausstecher und da habe ich
ihn von dort ganz dünn ausgerollt und
stellt jetzt damit die blumen aus
die blumen liegen jetzt auf seine
schaumstoff pet jetzt brauche ich hier
dieses bald ruhe und kann damit die
ränder hier auskennen und so fährt man
einfach an den rändern hier entlang und
dadurch bekommen die blumen so ein
bisschen struktur und zum trocknen lege
ich sie dann hier in so einem blumen
schildchen rein oder ihr legt sie auch
wieder in teelöffel rein
ich lasse jetzt die blumen noch ein
bisschen trocknen und kann ihn derzeit
schon mal die etwas modellieren
dafür nehme ich ein kleines stück roten
von dort holz zu einer kugel und wenn es
ein bisschen klebt nehmen wir einfach
ein bisschen becker stärke so an die
fingerspitzen und jetzt vorm ich daraus
fast einen kegel also eine spitze vorne
und hinten leicht flach und sobald euch
die form gefällt könnt ihr eine
spritztour nehmen und zwar ist eine ganz
kleine loch töne und damit markiere ich
jetzt hier noch die kleinen körper
und weil sie etwa in der natur auch
nicht alle gleich aussehen ist es da
auch nicht schlimm in einer kleine und
ein etwas größer wird oder wenn die form
etwas unterschiedlich ist
jetzt habe ich den grünen teil der
erdbeeren und viele fragen mich immer
mit was kann man den modellieren also
man kann einmal mit von dem unternehmen
wenn man denn von dort mit etwas cnc
also zellulose pulver verknetet oder man
kann auch mit modelle schokolade
modellieren und deswegen zeigen euch
diesen teil jetzt mit grüner modelle
schokolade die rolle ich jetzt dünn aus
und dann arbeite ich auch hier wieder
mit ausstechen wenn wir jetzt diesen
hier und sticht damit diese blüten
zeichens nur aus den grünen teil und
damit kann ich sogar noch ein bisschen
prägen und hab dann hier noch ein
bisschen struktur drin
jetzt wird der grüne teil noch an die
erdbeere daran geklebt dafür nämlich
etwas zucker kleber also essbaren kleber
der kommt dann hier oben direkt dran
dann wird angeklebt und die spitzen die
kann man es natürlich auch an kleben
muss man aber nicht ich lasse sie immer
gerne ein bisschen locker dann sieht es
nicht so angeklebt aus dann kommt hier
hinten ein kleines lächeln und ich forme
aus einem ganz kleinen stück modelle
schokolade noch den stil und klebt denn
hier rein
und die das jetzt so kurz trocknen bevor
ich sie dann noch etwas bemale die
blumen sind jetzt an getrocknet und
damit die etwas schöner werden nehme ich
jetzt gelbe pulver farbe und fordere die
ganz trocken direkt in die blume einfach
so ein bisschen nur in die mitte
b
die gelben blumen die geprägt waren die
kann man jetzt theoretisch so lassen
bei den anderen würde ich jetzt noch ein
paar perlen mit rein kleben
die deko taylors jetzt einfach schön
durch trocknen und kann in dieser zeit
bereits meine torte mit ghanas
bestreichen und mit von darüber ziehen
die touchpads glatt gestrichen und steht
noch im kühlschrank jetzt werde ich sie
mit von dort über 10
und dieses mal nehme ich diesen erdball
von dort und zwar ist der etwas sondern
mit echtem erdbeer mag das sieht man
auch wenn man anschaut das sieht mir
immer überall diese erdbeer stückchen
und allein schon bei meinen auspackt
richts richtig lecker nach etwa und
genauso schmeckt er auch ich nehme ein
kilo davon
jetzt stelle ich noch das letzte deko
element für die torte her und zwar einen
spitzendeckchen
dafür habe ich jetzt wieder hier etwas
von dor mit cnc pulver verknetet
ausgerollt sticht da so ein großes
blümchen aus blume versuch rosetten
förmig jetzt arbeite ich mit lochte in
verschiedenen größen und sticht so ein
paar löcher 1
und jetzt mache ich noch ein ganz langes
toten waren das lege ich nämlich gleich
als bordüre um die torte und damit ich
das band ist richtig schön gerade
schneiden kann nämlich hier dieses
musicals einfacher jetzt habe ich hier
das lange band ausgerollt und jetzt
nämlich einfach einbauen dürfen stanser
und stand die bordüre noch schön aus
die bordüre rolle ich jetzt auf einen
kleinen holzstab auf so kriege ich sie
nämlich leichter an die torte ohne dass
sie reißt
dann einmal unten absetzen jetzt
schreibe ich das kleber direkt an die
torte hier ganz am anfang lebe ich nur
ein bisschen was an die bordüre damit es
auch gut hält und drücke ich es hier an
und kann es dann mit hilfe des
holzstapels rollen
mit sie am ende ein bisschen weiter
rollen und dann mit einem scharfen
cuttermesser direkt am übergang
wegschneiden und da passt die bordüre
zwar nicht ganz aber der teil
verschwindet einfach hinten
jetzt kann ich direkt die erdbeeren und
die blumen drauf legen und die können
wir natürlich legen wie ihr möchtet ich
krebs jetzt natürlich auch noch an dann
fallen sie nämlich nicht runter und ich
hab jetzt überlegt ich mach das so ein
krampf ich legte jetzt zuerst und wenn's
mir angewöhnt dank lewis sein
jetzt ist meine torte fast fertig die
kann man natürlich jetzt auch schon so
lassen
ich werde es noch auf das deckchen für
mama schreiben denn das sei eine
muttertags torte aber natürlich kann man
auch was anderes drauf schreiben und
dafür nehme ich jetzt lebensmittel
farbstifte und der von daum muss dafür
leicht angetrocknet sein
jetzt kann man die torte probieren so
ich es jetzt den kugeln deiner mutter ja
sozusagen die mutterkuh gut er war
richtig gut was gar nicht sein auch mal
wieder einzigen meine witze lacht ich
selber gespannt murat wie du denn jetzt
geschmacklich findest dann kann ich eine
sahnetorte darunter egal der
enkelkindern oder waren spaß ich mag den
hut ich weiß
mein messer war nicht so scharf ich
merke ich gerade
ok also was soll auf jeden fall ein
scharfes messer nehmen an sich hier
unten habe ich jetzt den wiener boden
dann eine schicht erdbeeren
ich hab die holunderblüten sahne creme
oben drauf dann noch die minsk rehm und
jetzt dachstock werden ob ich es nie zur
geschichte ok also davon dann wird der
schmeckt den sr mit auf jeden fall und
oben halt noch eine schicht kann weil
der schmeckt wirklich klasse das oben
was ist das forum das ist weiße kann
ehrhoff ist diese schnelle hatte
zuschauer warte auf deinen auf dein
feedback
jetzt kommt die minsk rehm mit
holunderblüten super jetzt die erdbeer
schicht mit adware holunderblüten
cremona und ärzte und deine lieblings
also ich persönlich wurscht und reden
von unten anfangen also wirklich klasse
ja offenbar wenig in diesem video ganz
toll dass man auch mal gesehen habe wie
man eine sahnetorte von landtag nicht
bekommt und ich finde die zahl so
komplett von innen nach außen von außen
nach innen wunderschön und vor allem
sehr lecker mit diesem etwa von lotto
wünsche ich auch bekomme ich einen
morast
also falls ihr eure mutter oder ihrem
papa über 80 oder demo nicht ausreden
lassen will macht einfach mit oft genau
dann könnt ihr diese torte gerne
nachbacken natürlich könnt ihr eine
füllung nehmen die ihr gerne mögt ich
finde die füllung sehr toll vor allem
passt ihr zur jahreszeit kommentiert
nicht mehr ist egal wie weh das knie weh
das grüne eminem deswegen hab ich dir
nicht so lasse ich einfach nicht
aussprechen okay nein also falls ihr
noch mal die torten machen wollt geht
auch celis - block der eder steht noch
mal genau und ich sag dir nochmal für
meine mama also bis bald
also solange mittwoch an alle mieter
dann will ich als auch an deinen mut und
dann deine dass meine mutter aufs spiel